hallo mein name ist bekannt wir spielen
heute das so borst game auf 2015
das kann nur gut erhalten wir haben drei
auswahlmöglichkeiten new game contini
und schotter und wenn die stadtbrücke ja
war irgendwie dummen ist klar dass das
spiel an abstürzt wir gehen jetzt
einfach mal auf die game und das ganze
ding startet wir sind dieser kleine kerl
hallo hallo auf jeden fall also möchte
ich meine kinder später wochenend volcom
to my world games 2005 team gewann mit
rage and bring danke okay was was müssen
jetzt hier machen müssen wir hier
irgendwo müssen wir runter oder somit
wie im voraus keiner möchte ich laufe
gerade jeden einzelnen gang hier ab man
kommt nirgendwo raus ist dass ihr das
komplette spiel ist dass das komplette
spiel ich muss doch irgendwie vielleicht
hier runter irgendwo in den schwarzen bh
den weg gefunden
okay wir springen als einfach mal runter
world 5015 mann rammte ihr müsst euch
das so vorstellen so ein typ der heißt
du weißt man auf tücher oder irgendwie
so der typ heißt world game auf 2015 und
da steht vor einem abgrund strikt runter
stirbt und da kommt die meldung erfolg
alles klar
thomas hat tatsächlich was gebracht wir
sind umschlungen von lavao
wenn mir fährt raus gerade krankenwagen
lang die kommt schon mich abzuholen was
eine ironie alter ich bring darunter der
typ stier drosselt krank war
für das ok
komm mit mir robot trial
das ist doch nicht so schwer so der ju
kam hier bleibt da muss irgendein trick
drin sein okay wenn i ch news amy okay
okay
hey hey hey god damn it know you're
ready to go horrorfilm level failed
state of play game
das basler bla bla bla bla sei schön
wieder die klippe herunter samt on here
ok go to bed sex es wieder diese ganze
dumme unterhaltung hier alles klar solch
und tod jetzt rede ich mit dem typen
oder delta pressen blabla als der hbla
okay ich sag jetzt frei er sagt bei non
olet eigenheim
bei dieser last morningstar said that
they will be quiet hey hey hey gott der
mit finally nori ready for health hätten
ok ich sage bei bei non olet strike nok
ich sage bei dallas war nie und ich sage
sogar bei you are fired game komplett
tanks vom ich glaub ich hab den sinn des
spiels erkannt ich bin ja in den tod
gesprungen und der tod wollte mir dann
sagen ja du bist jetzt hier bleib aber
verpiss dich würde ich bin so aufgeregt
habe und er meinte dann jagd geht kommen
wir machen jetzt ein bisschen horror
aber dadurch dass gefeuert wurde lebe
ich jetzt wieder denn das der sinn des
spiels sein soll ich teste mal gerade
noch ob ich nicht irgendwo wenn ich
unterdrücke wieder irgendwo hingehen
kann oder so aber ich denke das sollte
diesmal tatsächlich der typ ist
unsichtbar auch jetzt kommen diese ganze
scheiße nochmal okay sagt ich mache mal
so ich darf jetzt seine letzte geld
jetzt sage ich jetzt mal heim und ich
habe schon wieder vertagt game completed
thanks for plague dankeschön freunde da
dieses video so scheiße war habe ich
gesagt ich mach da habe ich mir gerade
überlegt dass heute abend noch ein
zweites video kommt man als ausnahme
okay dann setzte ich mich noch mal dran
war nochmal neues video von einem
anderen spiel oder so was haltet ihr
davon wollt ihr das daumen hoch daumen
runter kommentar nein bleiben
das video ist allerdings noch relativ
kurzen sich allerdings noch eine minute
kurz was sagen möchte mache ich das
jetzt eben wenn ihr das video seht ist
am samstag heute gerade und ich fahre
nach wales beziehungsweise fliege mit
max extrakte das ist dieser hässliche
braunhaarige tu dir werden dort fünf
tage an der küste rum fahren mit dem
auto und alle möglichen sachen machen
und chillen und das blocken und das
alles mögliche die ganze blocks werden
allerdings erst ein bisschen später
hochgeladen werden dafür zwar während
der fahrt alles filmen das allerdings
nicht während der fahrt bearbeiten
sondern während der fahrt das ganze
einfach nur die reise genießen
deswegen werden wir das so machen wir
werden jeden tag film blabla aber alles
einfach abspeichern auf der sd karte
beziehungsweise auf dem laptop und das
dann irgendwann nachdem wir sind am 10
september wieder da nach dem zehnten
september werden wir das alles
bearbeiten und dann irgendwann hochladen
damit ihr dann die kompletten block
south wales hat allerdings in den
nächsten tagen also von heute von
samstag dem 5 bis nächste woche mittwoch
dem neunten sind videos vorproduziert
und ihr könnt auf twitter unter dem
hashtag motrip unsere reise verfolgen
und uns sachen posten und so weiter das
wollte ich mir eben kurz an kündigen
falls da irgendwas schief läuft von
wegen uploads und so ist es meine schuld
aber ich kann gut tanzen